[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
basically like you helped me to play
math and self-awareness so when it's in
the two minutes here because that's
tough you can kind of tell me on Twitter
what would be what do you need like
what's on your mind like what do you
think like what are you trying to make
happen honestly I've been trying to
think about that I don't know I'm good
I just want to handle I was not aware so
good honestly that's a good answer
that's why I just ask you that you don't
need to [ __ ] yourself here's what I
would tell you surround yourself with
good people as much as possible yeah
like that will work itself out right you
understand yeah like like when I said
good people I don't need people that
have been successful necessarily I mean
people that are like people that look
good yeah and just like to the right
thing you need to make sure that all
those people we think that you're coming
from a place of bringing value and
patience not trying to network in that's
the fine line that's everybody that's
what we always debate with things like
this is what Ross thinks about is what
Gilbert thinks about is this kid trying
to just get in or is this kid trying to
provide value and knows in 13 years that
will be beneficial to him you need to
convince the market through a players
that's the ladder
stay in this site trashy girl cuz she
died nice right way then I hey how are
ya
I'm [ __ ] pissed
[Music]
no I like watch your videos [ __ ] you man
you're like the most grateful for every
man concerning Ryan Ryan Thanks what if
I give it to her first
yeah I did not expect to graduate
assistant free don't worry my man thank
you for time we're asking again thank
you
oh it's what I work for never settle for
less
always one more shot straight from the
bottom what's it very good that's a
pleasure
oh yeah Romero what's your name darling
Dominic yeah no pleasure bank yeah thank
you're in here yeah we come from Chicago
moving here nobody knew how the
marketers I'm over it now we actually
have API very cool man oh you can take
them talk I am yeah thank you my email
actually I didn't know
yeah how much I'm going to sleep in this
in the conference yeah sure I figured a
DC registered
I don't think let's give him a bag okay
okay ten times better I heard how you
sound need to take a [ __ ] by the way
you found blood from the start they were
spending shadow minutes any rapper
period [ __ ] faces pitted where the
rocky wanna start podcasting and
vlogging do you have any advice you know
my advice is you know my face my face
part I know you know it you know
everybody knows my bike and I get what
listen I needed to in different areas
you just need expiry there's nothing
there's just nothing that is scared of
like what like like you know it's all
about who judges who write like if you
understand it like I'm going to look
like you're trying out and like this the
whole transitions and I have to go
through it is just hard it's super hard
but it but it's fine it right but a
binary good finder these are you doing
or you know to me for me what I do with
my content is try to eliminate the fear
because the fear is going to show me
back the question is for who like from
your parents from your contemporaries
from a random person with an anonymous
account that leaves a comment so the
questions are also your truth like
you're experiencing something millions
of people doing which is your keynotes
and I created document versus create
think about being a [ __ ] international
student you come out Bangladesh and
speak about Michigan speaking out yeah
packing being a volunteer here for this
moment exceed about [ __ ] take back [ __ ]
there's a fair says it thank you good
morning I stand up here of somebody
that's obsessed with HR obsessed with
people look at it as a financial offense
because I believe in retention and
continuity which then is a gateway to
speed which is an advantage when you
compete against any other visit me is
the ROI it is the differentiator in
sports and in business speed is what
matters and continuity and having people
stay in a place for a long time leads to
speed but even more importantly the
thing that leads to speed and execution
is when our employees don't have to sit
at their desk and think about politics
of dumb [ __ ] and actually think about
the work and the reality is all of this
appreciating that's the punchline right
I'll take that class thank you bro
it's just true it's staggering how much
percentage of every single employee in
the world right this second is thinking
about how to navigate through the
political matrix versus getting the
actual work done you know we give
presents on everybody yearly anniversary
when you give somebody a present that's
a fishing lure versus a [ __ ] $25
Amazon gift card you actually are
speaking to giving a [ __ ] versus
checking the [ __ ] box and I'll leave
with this I was born in the Soviet Union
let me tell you the difference between
communism and capitalism in communism
you put people in a box and they play
within it in capitalism we give people
freedom and when you do something wrong
we put you in a box
it is flabbergasting to me that all of
your companies in a capitalistic
environment are putting people in a box
I know more about my organs
thank you I know more about my
organization because of unlimited
vacation policy and safety and culture
because it's how I get an indicator at a
macro because when you give people
unlimited rope you actually figure out
who they are versus what all of you are
dealing with which is people are
navigating through the system you
created and you actually have no real
feel for who they are
thank you you're amazing thank you so
mines really what are like the top three
traits that you look for in a person is
empathy
obsessed with empathy empathy drives
everything if you actually understand
the other person more or what they're up
to or why they're driven or what their
background is so I'm obsessive empathy
gratitude you know I'm fascinated by
gratitude like if you're actually
grateful you're in a happy place like
your filter is happy and I think if you
are happy you're imposing that on other
people I think it's an incredibly
important leadership skill it's tough to
help other people if you're not in a
good place right and then probably
humility right so I think the way we are
winning a saner
when we win is just you have the
capability of being the bigger man or
woman in every situation
[Music]
very nice one I've got to get a book for
selfie and to do all new cheese by Gary
Vee or Gary Vaynerchuk
oh whatever you want what do you prefer
them I Pete these are super fine okay
that's um you know I'm all for resin you
know what's funny here is know it's
funny
yes funny that's just another example
like what matters and what doesn't right
a lot of like what which version of that
like the content we talk about is what
matters right cool
and then I am out of time people people
like Gary van der shotgun like you know
loves van der people really holy like at
school like it's funny that we in
America like add that like kind of
Nordic and like it feels natural to make
it standard always been fascinated by
that we have large brands are in serious
pain you know trying to figure out you
know what is our culture how do we
create you know messaging it gets
complex you some anymore slide and that
for sure for - for sure
but the reality is I don't have any
empathy for these leaders that come to
me and say I'm struggling with this when
every decision out of her or his mind is
predicated on hitting numbers for Wall
Street in a 90 day window like stop
talking out of both sides are mouth you
actually don't care about culture which
is by the way great new [ __ ] [ __ ]
me because we're having that
conversation right now all your forget
about what any of us say show you what
people are doing there is absolutely
zero luck involved in the Steelers
Patriots Giants like this is
organizational from the top from
ownership because you know what I say a
Boehner that's super important
everything's my fault because it's true
it's the chief blank think I hired chief
length so from quarterback to GM to
defense a coordinator to the training
staff to HR which i think is going to
end up being a
advantage we're going to win because I'm
going to be the owner and the quality of
the people is going to be extraordinary
and if I make the wrong choice which I
will especially in the beginning because
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing I
will be quick to own those mistakes and
change them out I don't need my own spot
naima trained for 19 it can show me I
feel good about so it's more than you
read it all and there's no there's no
oh right that's the game yeah so it's
kind of like instead of like do my inbox
go to zero then do yours and do
logistics it's read my inbox I noticed
you made that switch a little bit right
and then get you to a place where like
you're gonna get employment yeah being
strategic about when you clean it right
you didn't do it yesterday at all but
now midday time sleep you know red eye
who cares I'm asleep let me do anyway
nuances for that nuances just such
little things the little things are
better which don't matter nothing
matters while in parallel the little
things I mean that's just what it is
it should him that's it you know next 24
hours stickers iMessage stickers maybe
Gary bi master stickers so pumped that
Snickers are coming
iMessage Iowa's interest next 24 hours
guaranteed stickers stickers d-roc not
sure what kind of episodes gonna be for
Barack obviously very early give a
keynote obviously around HR something
I'm passionate about but here in San
Francisco now it's pretty this early
flight for us usually thinking a little
later excited but I love the fact that
I'm gonna be able to crush email for
four and a half five hours and you know
so many things are just not super sexy
right like some of you who are cynical
characters which I feel bad for except
the defensive mechanism asked me like
what do you do Gary being like things I
can just go them talk and there are
readings all day roll your youngsters
that are razzing me with that winners
architects like nice to carry boxes and
take the nature with some of the stuff
that's mundane and fear awful try to
remind me to take a selfie is I'm going
to answer 800 people vino right now
dancers [ __ ] architects yeah you know
what is the conductor is that what if
it's called the orchestra nothing like
[ __ ] the conductor do Charles
there's kid Charles what do you can get
Charles the conductor [ __ ] waves
singers around right like playing the
violins have a cheese she's [ __ ]
conductor so while we're still in the
trenches trying to figure your [ __ ] out
what you understand the [ __ ] is
now sometimes the conductors got to play
the [ __ ] violin I'm going to go play
the violin for five and a half hours and
answer very mundane beep very contextual
very simple dog [ __ ] things that I have
to do to get you know winners play up
here and down here obviously like me
answering emails and all that stuff is
not necessarily you know compelling blah
blah that's not laptop anymore is it
we're saying like if I would fill myself
an email for you I give everything on my
boat can't do both right now just one
here ah can feel that way because the
first class so we've got fancy you might
be halfway to the first class and so
we'll see if that happens anything at
all and you can see me doing my [ __ ]
email campaign that I'm going to turn
into my favorite super
airport Gary
he goes from normal entrepreneur
be Charles it's a little question for
you friend
[Music]